[Music]
hello hello everyone shrinking CSS this
is the about me slide a friend
challenged me to use this so contrary to
the popular belief this is not me but uh
all right these are my credentials and
on the agenda today let's start with a
bit of a rant
um so my main motivation behind this
thing is that I don't really know CSS
and this was sort of a learning
experience I was hoping by learning to
par CSS in minifi I'll learn
something this thing is hard uh so
luckily for me and you uh Patrick is
going to talk about uh the critical path
in CSS and Nicole is going to talk about
performance so I don't have to give you
my performance uh motivation but um the
main thing is that every everything else
on the page is or can be
asynchronous other than CSS uh it's on
the way of rendering anything on the
page so have to make sure
it's as small as it possibly
can the rant with CSS uh one of the
problems with CSS is that it's too easy
almost so you you find something and
then you style it and it's almost too
easy and it's surprising that anyone
should be paid money to do this thing
right but but then it becomes very very
quickly becomes really really hard so
when you try to lay something out on a
page uh Center something you know all
those things block formatting Contex
specificity Cascade inheritance all all
those things actually that's a pretty
good uh list if you're interviewing
someone and ask uh the candidate to
explain to you one of those topics it
becomes hilarious pretty
quickly and this is what the cord had to
say about CSA say it's long fragile list
of self-contradictory
rules and maybe you have seen this thing
right CSS everything is oh my God so why
did I write all those things why did I
send it to the browser and all my users
have to download this thing it's all not
needed
right so um CS being so hard the result
is that it it it quickly becomes uh very
big and out of proportion and um
refactoring this thing is is almost
impossible you have to just sit down and
scrape everything and start over if you
want to have any sort of clean
code the solution to that CSS problem is
that we can learn CSS right and uh
luckily recently there's been a lot of
talk about architecting CSS and uh
making it reusable and so on I have a
few pointers at the end uh but meanwhile
while we learn CSS we can Minify the
stuff that we have so far that's with
the
rant so um I think looking at the the
available CSS minif files out there I
think we're leaving a lot of stuff on
the table and um the existing minifiers
are either based on regular Expressions
uh like the yui Cs minifier or based on
some sort of parser that I called
partially parsing because um see this is
what you get in in JavaScript what you
what you like to have right some sort of
okay this is my CSS rule I have a bunch
of selectors and I have some
declarations and it's looks nice and uh
and I can work with that I can uh see if
I can Minify any of those but as you can
see this is this isn't really proper uh
syntax tree because you there are some
values that you still have to pass and
figure out what's going on and it
quickly becomes all right so if if I'm
given this string how how do I decide
what to Minify and what what to rewrite
and so on uh so I still have to do some
parsing so that's why I call those uh
partial parsing partial passers and
quickly especially with more complicated
properties like the background right I
don't even have enough room here um so
how you deal with that how how do you
find what to rewrite
here uh so I I was contributing to the
yui CSS minifier which is based on
regular expression and there's no parsel
so you have things like that uh some
horrendous looking regular Expressions
that are meant to strip some spaces they
work pretty well most of the time uh
right you can strip spaces here you can
strip spaces here but turns out that I
know in C for example you cannot just
blindly strip spaces around the plus
sign because it matters uh so it it
quickly becomes uh not so powerful in
terms of what sort of minification it
can do
so um looking at the the bug cue that
people are sending oh I want to Minify
this and this is not working so on said
okay this thing needs a parer and I'm
going to write me one and um I tried and
uh then I abandon it um it was years ago
um there was no CCS pars written in
JavaScript yet uh uh so I said okay I'm
even going to do some you know pull a
crockford here and and do a little
diagrams and you know figure out how to
parel those
things uh
turns out it's more work than I was
willing to do so I forgot all about it
and then I I came back to it and say
okay there there's now CSS parsel out
there and I chose this one called mench
by uh Brett simmerman so at this point
there's uh the Nik Zas and Nico have the
CSS lint which has a CSS parer uh there
TJ What call uh has a CSS parer as well
used in in this really nice tool code
rework uh um and it was also a partial
parcel right it will give me the the
values but then I have to pass through
them as well um and I was I I got pretty
far there but uh when it comes to
minifying
um CSS short hands like font and
background and so on uh because when you
write a minifier right where there's any
sort of shortening that's where you
should be spending time uh so then I had
to par all those things so then
eventually I gave it up uh and found
this other parser called Gonzalez which
has a better syntax tree um much more
detailed and it looks something like
this it's not very easy to work with
because it's all arrays uh right but uh
at least I don't have to pass the font
tag because it has already right
dimensions uh identifier right strings
operators and all that stuff so this is
something I can work with
although it's not all that uh easy to
you know pass through a race
uh and the result was this tool I called
CSS shrink uh so you can go to uh what
is it
CSS
shrink and play with it it's not feature
complete yet it's not where I I wanted
to be but um I'll learn some stuff along
the way that I wanted to share with you
um um so but I know you can you can
write some stuff and see the uh the
results here minified and then kind of
pretty what was stripped and what was
before and
after
so I'll quickly run through all the the
sort of stuff that you can do to CSS to
Minify it
um the first thing to do of course is to
strip all the all the unnecessary spaces
and
comments uh and this is this this is
pretty safe uh transform that you can do
and in fact I uh I have this as a
separate tool called pretty ugly uh that
you can pry or uglify css only when it
comes to comments and uh and
spaces next colors right
uh there's a there's a uh Library npm
called color I think uh that I used uh
it's basically just Brute s and take any
color value uh and get all the all the
available representations of it and pick
the the smallest one right so as as a
side effect uh it also supports uh uh
hsl and and all that other syntaxes so
if you use this sort of minifier you can
you can uh you can use hsl which then
will be Rewritten if possible it it will
become RGB uh or if it's smaller it
become one of those
so that's a nice side
effect zeros and numbers right um most
of the time you can you can strip uh the
unit from from zero values most of the
time not always uh you can also strip
percentages most of the time uh you can
strip leading
zeros quotes So if if any sort of
minification fails uh the least I can do
is uh is be consistent and hope that
this thing helps with the with gzipping
so just using consistent quotes and and
removing the quotes where where uh
possible right turns out let's say for
example in font family you don't need
those those quotes although we we all
use them when you have a list value the
com is
enough key frames if I see the word from
I make it zero% if I see 100% I make it
two because it's shorter right uh all
the uh pseudo selectors um
they have this this old syntax which is
a little
shorter uh and and there's a there's a
quirk in IE that needs to be addressed
so uh IE filters right I don't have
enough room I guess to show this whole
thing but um there's this uh there's
this syntax that people use uh for for
IE uh filters but turns out that there's
something called I4 syntax which is much
much shorter so so any of any of those
values can be transformed to this uh
shorter thing the the worrying thing is
if if you read about I filters on msdn
uh it's uh warns you against using those
short uh filters because for performance
reasons but um I spoke to some people
from from IE and Microsoft and they say
this is you should ignore this uh even
even I mean it it doesn't doesn't matter
in the grand scheme of things uh at all
and maybe it's it's just historical but
at this point it doesn't matter at all
if it mattered so don't be worried about
if you see warnings about
performance uh B can be shorter normal
font weight can be
shorter like I said if everything else
fails the least I can do is make
everything consistent so using
consistent uh lower case everywhere and
hope this helps G Zing next there are
some structural changes that that uh
that uh we can do to unify stuff right
uh if you if you have any empty thing or
or some invalid CSS in here so this
thing should should be should go uh if
you have duplicate declarations right uh
the last one wins in this case you know
even after the the colors are
transformed then you you find out that
this is actually the same the same
declaration so you can strip the one
above duplicate selectors it happens
right if you have the same selector
twice
you can remove one of
them adjacent selectors right you if you
have uh two selectors right after each
other uh then you can merge the
Declaration uh the Declarations inside
of them if you have blocks that happen
to be the same right after each other
then you can merge the selectors uh and
uh and have one
block if have adjacent everything has to
be adjacent uh with is this because they
that matters um if you have ajacent
media prop
um media queries then uh then you can
merge those as well and there is a whole
bunch of other random nonsense that can
be uh fixed right if you have uh more
than one generic font that doesn't make
any sense but it happens out there so
uh you can strip uh anything but the
first generic font right serif s serif
that sort of thing um Believe It or Not
people write inv valid CSS which then
the browsers will have to uh remove uh
so it would be great if we don't send it
to the browser at
all uh and there's some some other uh
things that are a little bit more
dangerous um you know some some uh
properties that don't make sense uh but
uh it's a little dangerous like if you
have uh if you have zero border uh why
do you care about the color of this
border since it doesn't exist right but
uh the problem is that you might have
some JavaScript manipulating the CSS and
then suddenly it matters so that's a
little bit more dangerous and something
to avoid uh writing CSS with Java scrip
if possible short hands of course uh the
the sort of trouble properties top right
bottom left uh they can be uh and they
can be merged into shorthand fonts
borders backgrounds and all that good
stuff uh that's a a perfect thing to to
Minify you can
we can do some unit conversions right if
you have 100 1,000 milliseconds it's
shorter to say it's just one second
right um even crazy things like this
using inches instead of pixels uh so uh
just going quickly through this thing so
if if you see any if I see anything
stupid just please tell me um afterwards
and uh it's an open source project so
I'm just looking for any more ideas for
to Minify or any anything stupid I may
be
doing if you have duplicate key frames
right uh the second one should
win uh and then renaming so that that's
a problem with with minifying CSS unlike
JavaScript where you can mify the
variable names uh there's not much uh
that you can Minify let's say uh
helvetic a new helvetic a sound serif
right there's no way to Minify this
thing but uh luckily now we have CSS
variables which are also um
uh supported in some browsers so uh
that's a that's a perfect thing to to
Minify use variables where we
applicable all right uh the problem with
the I think the purpose of this talk is
mostly convincing you that we can do
some some CSS transformation and
shouldn't be afraid to do because now
everyone everyone does some sort of
JavaScript transformation right if you
want to support EAS script six features
um but we're not so comfortable making
CSS uh transforms but uh we should be uh
so um even if you cannot for some reason
use less uh or any of those
pre-processors that doesn't mean you
cannot do any any CS transformation on
your own but then how do you know that
works right how do you know that you
didn't break
anything uh so while working on this
minifier I had to do a bunch of other
uh
tools and uh this is where npm is uh
invaluable uh because you can split uh
your work into different uh sub modules
or you can use modules that exist
already so that's perfect so uh ended up
creating a whole bunch of npm packages
um uh this one is just uh oh yeah by the
way so there's this side uh this um the
main name was expiring so I snch that
it's not really beautiful site but it
just has a bunch of uh
links so if you if you want to
contribute to the project or or do any
sort of uh transformation then this is
one of the tools that you can use to
say
right whatever and explore the uh the a
that uh that you can use then to
manipulate
that CSS yeah so how do you make sure
that you didn't break anything in your
CSS transformation
um CSS test battery just a bunch of uh
all all the CSS files from CSS and
garden and some popular Ries that you
can use to
test uh this is probably my favorite BS
CSS um and this is something that I urge
you to explore um and not send CSS to
the browsers that don't know what to do
with
it um so that's why this Sub sub project
called CSS properties where you just uh
see what um uh just enumerate all the
properties that the browser supports and
then you can say okay if if this browser
doesn't support this property then I can
safely remove it I mentioned about uh
pretty prettyy and
uglifying uh yeah so that's the beauty
of of npm that uh I found a color
library that I can use so uh instead of
doing the the CSS color Transformations
on my own I can just uh write another
library that that uses this one and just
does does the minification of
colors uh things that coming up so I
mentioned CSS uh
shorthand uh which is something that the
minifier should do but mine doesn't yet
uh and uh in order to do that then you
have to validate the CSS before that
right because when you start parsing the
phone tag for example um because things
can be in different order and then you
have to to validate that this is a
regular tag so um that's pending on this
link Tool uh before I can do the short
hands so I mentioned about the CSS diff
um right so you you have a CSS before
and you do some transformation and you
have CSS after so just run in the
browser uh before and after take a
screenshot and compare all the pixels
and see if there's anything uh different
after the transformation if there is
even a single Pixel that means something
broke so I'm using Phantom JS for web
kit Slimmer JS for uh Firefox trifold JS
for iie and there's there's a project
called DJs which is I think almost there
that does all of these things and
more um so that's something you can
explore so I mentioned that the bsss
um a lot of people not comfortable doing
the uh server side sniffing but um I
think it's it's necessary evil in this
case so oh the horror I have to sniff uh
on the server side what kind of browser
it is and send it only the the CSS it
understands uh which I think is a worthy
goal and uh have to bite the bullet and
do some server side sniffing so uh you
can remove um uh prefixes and any
unsupported properties let's say IE
hacks so so Firefox Chrome they don't
need to know anything about star hacks
and underscore hacks and so on um and um
yeah actually I tried with bootstrap in
in uh in some old IE you can actually if
you use that BS bscs you can safely
strip half of it uh in I and just
there's too much going
on just a quick thing if you if you want
to contribute to the project uh it's
using this um visitors pattern where any
any CSS transform is is a visitor and
lives in different files so it's kind of
manageable and it looks like this right
so you you create a if you want to add a
feature you create a uh a module that
contains a test and a process method so
you test whether or not you should do
any transform here and then you you do
it in in the process method uh so this
is the example of how simple it is the
uh to to make all the all the spaces
consistent right any tabs new lines and
so
on all right too much talken what what's
in it for me uh what have you learned
today uh you can try the the CSS shrink
uh like I said it's not feature complete
yet it works pretty well but uh there's
there's some more things that I would
like to add to it uh it's an APM module
so it can be part of the of the process
and I think uh people have already
written um plugins for for popular uh
static Resource Management Systems like
uh Gulp and and
grun um seriously consider uh the
browser specific CSS it just uh sending
we're sending too much CSS to the
browsers that just end up passing it and
throwing it away so why should the uh
the user suffer from this thing uh yeah
like I mentioned a lot of those tools uh
have um little demos that you can play
with right um so you feel free to
explore this thing uh let me just
quickly show you let's say we have uh we
have uh some CSS property that is
specific to IE right and then you can
see in the browser specific CSS say okay
how it's going to look in Firefox yeah
it's gone how it's going to look in uh
in
IE right it's there with with a prefix
stript um yeah so these These are the
type of uh you know kind of generic I
don't go into versions of chrome and
Firefox uh just just versions in I uh
but you can explore and just paste
something and see how how small it
becomes in a different
browser classes uh yeah so like I said
some of some of the modifications that
uh that we can do are sort of dangerous
uh in in that uh if you have JavaScript
manipulating CSS um then things by break
uh things that otherwise can be stripped
so it's always better to um don't do
that but instead use classes and change
them and um so there there's a bunch of
uh of new thinking about organizing CSS
and and architecting it there's Max CS s
uh objectoriented CSS anything by
Nicholas uh galaher and my favorite one
is this CSS for grumpy old man um it's
really beautiful
thing yeah don't be afraid to to
transform CSS uh that's that's what I
would like to encourage everyone to do
um why why leave all the fund for to
JavaScript uh and and do all the all the
sort of JavaScript transformation but
Lees you on the table so like I said
even if you cannot use uh less or any of
the pre-processors or postprocessors
that doesn't mean you cannot write your
own using any any of those parsers
available whether it's uh uh the
Gonzalez with a very detailed EST or or
something simpler right like rework it's
really really easy uh to do so things
like uh variables right which are more
more kind of a constants if you want to
transform them right there's no reason
why you shouldn't be using uh variables
these days right uh because it's been
missing from CSS for quite a while now
it's there but not in every browser so
why not just write modern CSS and have
this transformation process take care of
all the
browsers so um y uh you can transform
stuff like um like you can use more
modern ways to define a color or or
opacity and so on and leave it to the to
the transformation process to take care
of of the other
browsers and yep that's all I have today
thanks very
[Applause]
[Music]
much